hello everybody my name is LAM kirchi
and it is my pleasure to take you to the
next 10 minutes when I summarize my
team's progress and the plans for the
future
will present to you the Recon series a
set of solutions to microbiology and
metagenomics that added course Champions
the principles of early reduction uh
focused diseases are neurological
disorders and our first candidate in the
Recon series is the Alzheimer's disease
for today's agenda I should discuss the
situation and the proper solution for
the problem in the project summary then
we understand the possible road loss of
the solution both in a research
perspective and a business one following
this the presentation covers some
technology and discussions that we use
to find our solution through our
pipelines we wrap it up with the
business cases of concluding thoughts
about what's next for the team and this
project
we start with a simple scale study to
set the stage and fill in with every one
citizen there are four who are above 80.
the nation's population is predominantly
of senior citizens
with the model and mortality rate of 52
percent the problem is an existing one
in the 21st century
adding on to the all these red flags the
cost per patient powers in the
neighborhood of 24 000 Euros we can
estimate that the annual commitment to
such Health Facilities can amount to
upwards of three thousand million euros
foreign
population and is considered developed
this might not be a concern but it
becomes one for developing nations
support their population in an age of
customized and costly Healthcare
Solutions
so let's consider the problem as it is
taking its face value we are aware of
the rise and the overage population
developed countries this Cube rise in
senior population compared to the
younger or the non-earning and the
earning which is concerns about the
nation's future
for developing countries ability to Bear
the increase in economic spending for
healthcare facilities is a problem while
accessing tests for Alzheimer's disease
are invasive and costly
and are most often than not provided by
specialized centers
additionally some patients may also view
them as invasive
for the nature of these tests in
involved lumbar puncture or pet
and finally the burden is unfinely laid
on low to middle-income countries are 60
percent of 80 cases are reported in such
Nations
the solution exists the solution is
exists and have an ability to Aid
individuals in being aware for the need
of change for Alzheimer's diseases often
the result of habits and behaviors are
adopted by the individual over the
course of their life
early detection of microbial dysbiosis
or any changes in the gut brain
microbiome axis can go along when
helping individuals choose a better
quality of life our solution is a
microgram testing kit that detects
either the abundance or the absence or
specific bacterial species in the
current microbiome in doing so patients
flag with this biasis can be introduced
to a dinosaur supplements better health
habits to potentially avert the
potential problem
sounds easy enough doesn't it anyone
could find the population of bacteria
that will help anyone diagnose an
individual with the possibility of
developing Alzheimer's well it is an
easy and that is exactly what we
understood during the project
but focusing on the positives how will
our solution Work summer collection will
involve collection of fecals happens
from the individual these samples will
let me introduce the sample to our
testing cocktail
which through chemical reactions will
introduce can very visual indicators
which will allow for a visual
understanding
of either the absence of the presence of
macrobial dysbiosis all this is being
done to make it make it make the
platform easier for individuals to use
the presence of this biosity species
will be recommended to consume
supplements and change the habits
now for the components of the edk or the
early detection get account according to
us will involve the analyte the
bacterial population that indicates the
potential onset of Alzheimer's disease
the bioreceptor which in this case is
the cocktail which will be a combination
of enzymes and proteins
negative because the target microbial
population
finally the interface of the platform
will indicate the potential chances of
being diagnosed with ad
we believe that we can ensure and
develop a relative scale of measurement
and can reduce the chances to your
potential
percentage as a value for understanding
easily
now let's talk a bit about a
microbiology household project we
discuss more on this on our project
submission on the platform on this
logics
in the back project 821821 realized to
this data said that the specificity of a
cocktail is Paramount by using it this
is status as a common ground we found
resistance that helped us make a case
for the differences in current microgram
population between male and female
patients
it by project 734525
it was specifically chosen for the
variation and introduced through three
testing disease types ad Alzheimer's
healthy and minor cognitive environment
MCA
we understand that through such
different differences egg system that
will populace they're in different
neurological disorders different shared
in them is all the more important and
difficult
summing up in by project eight two one
eight two one we concrete that the
abundance of ruminococcus a in AWS can
be a competent candidate to serve as
analyte in the case of bad project
734525 it was privately
during the literature survey survey we
came across an interesting paper that
helped us conclude that we are on the
right track through this where we
compare that the form of cuties as a
general indicated population as a
positive test for Alzheimer's at a final
level
in the case of bacterial family
on the jackpot
coming to roadblocks to a solution
number one finding enough data to make a
strong case for feasibility and early
detection kit
access to domestic labs to test a
hypothesis and finally identifying
competent testing methodologies for our
cocktail
now let's talk about the business side
of things the team sincerely believes
that this solution can only make sense
and the purpose has a clear
understanding of how remain available to
Consumers and make it a profitable
Enterprise in the healthcare industry
by conducting a very simple and
rudimentary market analysis we came
across the title recommendation testing
kit by ombre which was priced at 99 to
make Micron testing it's a viable option
for healthcare professionals we must
make it affordable
the best of our knowledge we believe
that these are the funny expenditures we
will incur as you go forward number one
Hospital consultations we believe that
hospitals are an important facet of our
stakeholders and due to the proximity of
the patients they are in a better
position to understand the needs of the
patient
developing the testing cocktail this
will involves a Lion's Share of
expenditure for the student involves the
heart of the product
finally B2B contracts to make excuse me
to make our product available through
online vendors and microbiology labs for
the consumers directly
similarly we expect our revenue
generated in the following ways number
one sale of the testing cocktail
we believe that we can make the testing
company comparative between excessive
microgram testing platform hence the
primary revenue Source will be to the
sale of testing company
second in the fact that it's sales
Hospital clinics uh that are in position
to treat neurological disorders or see a
high influx of patient around the age of
40 can refer our product to the patients
as a safety net
how will all this work is it all about
by using the kanban method to
manufacture where we manufacture our
gets offering or resin placed foreign
strict quality control
then they assembled etk or the other
detections that will make will be picked
up by the vanter and lastly sold the
customer or the hospital
our Recon series will be arranged from a
45 dollar price tag to 90 price tag our
goal is to make this kit affordable to
the middle to low income Houser at 2027.
so what is next for us
for our first bullet point we identify
negative and positive tests for the
identified Battlefield family is
important secondly understand the
cautious relationship between the gender
and the chances of Alzheimer's thirdly
we have to finalize our literature
review draft
and lastly but not the least for now we
believe that teaching in the hospital is
the understand the need for a solution
and stakeholders hold similar importance
a proper stand line Looks something like
this
come December January you believe that
him practices will play a fighting role
in February we enter the logistics of a
project
welcome to a chain of thoughts we
believed that we first understood
there's an existing need for a detection
kit secondly I understood why
existing kids are concerned for the
healthcare industry third we went out to
identify specific populations of macular
spiers through our Pipelines
we did Serve by understanding two
specific correlations between the gene
inducing Alzheimer's disease and fecal
microgram secondly the biomarkers of
Amazon
microbiome and in the end what you see
in front of you is a combination of a
research in science and business as well
and there's a methodology that's pretty
straightforward we understood that our
data sets have to have two specific
status which means that they have to
have a control or a disease patient
status which is what we exactly found
after running our pipelines we analyze
them with four specific key indicators
as a philosophy number one being the
abundant
population in 80 compared to control
lassinating and abundant control
and similarly to other two other
examples of how a similar population
exists in both cases are they are absent
in both cases
finally we understand further
explicative resources required to
ascertain the fact carry the solution to
hypothetically attachment promise we
understand that the required clinical
testing to make it applicable for human
diagnosis remains a huge variable in our
Solutions future and finally we
understand the need for a robust supply
chain to ensure that the manufacturing
storage and the signals of this kit
takes place smoothly
in our team we have four passionate
individuals
we believe that we can change the world
finally at the end we believe that our
solution is very much similar to the
role of a lighthouse the solution is to
warn users and allow them to change
course in terms of one's habits and
other kind of supplements before it is
too late
and with that
and with the ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the end of this video I'd
like to thank you so much for listening
to me till the end and hope that we have
made a convincing case for the solution
proposed and the vision for making
everyone's lives safer and better
through microbiology this has been alarm
signing off